Buen día los congresistas Lady camones y
Diego Bazán son los encargados que van a
sustentar el informe ante el parlamento
peruano que recomienda acusar
constitucionalmente al expresidente
Pedro Castillo por los delitos de
organización criminal tráfico e
influencias y colusión se requieren 61
votos para que la acusación sea aprobada
y si es que esto sucede la fiscalía
quedará a disponibilidad
y de toda cargo para poder trasladar al
presidente Pedro Castillo ante al
expresidente Pedro Castillo ante los
tribunales de la justicia peruana
seguidamente en la jornada el parlamento
también va a debatir nuevamente la
Reforma por el adelanto de las
elecciones justamente en las últimas
horas la presidenta Dina boluarte ha
estado sosteniendo reuniones con los
líderes de los diferentes partidos
políticos para tratar de conseguir el
consenso y que la reforma salga adelante
algunas Fuentes señalan que ya se tienen
los votos para aprobar la reforma pero
como siempre sucede en política y sobre
todo en Perú A última hora cualquier
cosa podría ocurrir Francisco Qué
estrategias están prendiendo la defensa
de Pedro Castillo para obtener su
libertad y quizás pues una eventual
reposición en el cargo
los abogados de Pedro Castillo tienen
previsto acudir ante los tribunales
internacionales en las últimas horas el
Primer Ministro Alberto tarola ha
advertido que la defensa de Pedro
Castillo va a interponer una demanda
cautelar ante la Comisión Interamericana
de Derechos Humanos a esta demanda exige
su Liberación y que Castillo se ha
repuesto en el cargo de presidente de
los peruanos justamente Alberto tarola
le ha pedido al congreso a este país y
también a la fiscalía que aceleren los
casos en presunta corrupción que se
tiene contra Pedro Castillo porque según
lo señala otarola los casos de
corrupción son los que tienen menos
defensa ante los tribunales
internacionales